like that most speakers today have
touched upon but hopefully I'll give you
a more depth on the topic so let's get
started okay for scalability on on large
data sets what do you need for your
algorithm you need your algorithm to
have good locality and good but ilysm by
good locality we mean it needs to
minimize the amount of data at news in
the distance through which it moves the
data why is that because most machines
today have very non-uniform memory
systems for instance this is an intel
xeon these are numbers from Intel Xeon
system depending on where you place your
data that the time you take to access
the data can be either four cycles or
160 cycles for dram or if you go on to
the interconnect it's it's probably
10,000 cycles so if you want good
scalability first thing you would try to
do is place your data so that you
minimize the distance your data moves
the second objective is to minimize the
amount of data you know why because on
the system's you in the systems you have
several process and each of these
processes are capable of generating huge
amount of data or crossing a huge amount
of data on intel xeon each each code can
go through about 10 gbps of data per
second so 10 gb per second and you have
32 on a 32 go system that's about 300
gbps but your bandwidth bound you cannot
feed all of this process if they just
stream through the data at random
because you have this bottleneck hear
about of 100 gbps on a theorem and if
you go about that the band which you get
is even lower so to keep all your
process busy you need to minimize the
distance that you move your data through
and the amount of data you move and
obviously for power by Pavlov I mean you
have to maximize number of simultaneous
operations okay so loosely speaking this
is what locality and parallelism is now
are there formal ways formal definitions
for quantifying locality and parallelism
that's what this talk is going to be
about and this is not a new topic you've
seen some models today morning and this
research has been going on for 40 years
the first first well the first start
locality were in the context of VLSI
circuits and systolic is I won't go
there there are cost models for
sequential hierarchies I will touch upon
this topic and their cost models for
distributed memory machines for like the
supercomputers you see that the Titan
our MapReduce style systems there are
number of models for distributed memory
machines I will touch upon those and
there are models for shared memory
machines and I will talk about them in
detail okay and the outline of this the
outline of talk i'll give you some cost
model i'll show you some cost models for
distributed memory shared memory and
hierarchies now highlight some low
bounce and upper bounds in this cost
models and most importantly i will try
to convince you that there are two
different kinds of cost models machine
centric and program centric and and let
you choose the next time let you choose
between the two next time you use cost
models okay okay so where do we start we
start with a parallel program now
irrespective of the programming model
you use a respective of the system you
use a parallel probe parallel program
essentially boils down to directing a
directed acyclic graph or a dag so this
tag is a collection of instructions
these are the blue notes and data
dependencies between them and let's say
you have a distributed memory machine
machine in which each processor its has
its own memory of about size m and
there's an interconnect between these
things what is an execution of this
program on this machine so it's
essentially a partitioning of this dag
and mapping from of these partitions to
these processors now there's some
conditions on how you can partition this
tag you have to partition the stack so
that these these partitions fit in EM
size memory and you have two partitions
them so that their continuous you can't
have a partition that looks like this it
has to be contiguous if there is a path
from here to here it has to include all
of these okay so that's a valid
execution now let's look at this and try
to see how you might quantify locality
so how much communication would you
incur if you use this particular
partition it's all the red edges that
you see between these partitions right
so that's the amount of data you move
the amount of data you move is the
number of edges that go across
partitions and the distance through
which you move this data depends on the
interconnects so if this if this
processor if this node will map to this
processor and this node will back to
this process the distance through which
this edge travels depends on the
interconnect apology okay so that will
give you the distance now if you assume
that your interconnect has uniform
internal access costs you might this
might be one possible cost model for
locality you take a linear combination
of the number of words that you
transferred between notes and the number
of messages the blocked messages that
you transfer between the notes ok so
this is a very simple cost model this is
very similar to what oh the BSP model
let's all get talked about your morning
it slightly different it's a synchronous
but it's not too different and if you
want a cost model for time what would
you do you take the dag you define a
schedule on the dag which is a
partitioning and the mapping and for
partitioning X I and a mapping F from
partitions to process the time is
maximum overall process of the summation
of overall partitions that are mapped to
this processor of a linear combination
of instructions words and messages okay
so we are ex taking locality the cost
model for locality and plug and
extending it to generate a cost model
for time now the difficult part about
computing this cost model is that you
have to find a good partitioning right
or you have to find a good schedule so
this this is a this is a cost model that
depends not just on your algorithm that
or your dagger which is a program but
it's a cost model that also depends on
the schedule ok so you think about it
that's a difficult part of computing
this cost model ok so now given this
cost model you can also define how the
paralyzed ability of your algorithm so
the paralyzed ability of your algorithm
is the maximum number of
process where the where the written on
investment stops stops okay so if you
think of the best schedule for a
different number of process and you
increase number of processor at some
point you get no returns on adding more
process so that's maximum paralyzed
ability of your algorithm and you might
notice that it depends on the the effect
effective depth of this partition tag ok
so I've talked about a very simple cost
model for distributed memory machines
with a uniform all to all interconnect
now you might take this model and make
it more fancy and you can extend it to
different interconnect apologies or you
can add disks to it or you can add more
process / memory but ultimately all of
them almost all the car smells that you
can define will essentially boil down
some sort of graph graph partitioning
and that's the tricky part of this cost
model how do you compute a good graph
partition that's that's that's where the
creativity comes in this into this model
and to give upper bounds in this model
for problems you have to construct your
algorithm and you have to construct your
algorithm in such a way that you can
design a good schedule okay for instance
for dense matrix multiplication and if
you have the number if the number of
entrances of M times P which is the
memory per processor a number of process
you can construct with some with not too
much effort an algorithm that has into
the 1.4 instructions into the 1.5 x m to
the point five words and this many
messages of size M and the cost model
will and you can construct them such a
way that it's perfectly load balanced
and you get good bound on time you can
do something like that for sorting
except that now you have a lesser
locality here here you have a reuse of
to the extent of em to the point 5 here
you are reuse of log n so the ratio
between instructions and messages here
is polynomial and here it's log so this
is now got them with greater locality
and less locality but both of them are
extremely parallel and so on so to
define to get lower bounds in this model
what you would do is think about this
partitioning and kind add this
constraint on the partition you you you
force it this each partition to have at
most n by 2 incoming edges and by two
outgoing edges
and you ask the question what is the
partitioning with the fewest transfers
if you can compute this this objective
if you can find if you can compute this
if you can find a bound for this
objective on your dag you get a lower
bound and for again for matrix
multiplication it's the same as the
upper bound and you might notice that
this is not too hard to prove because
with M data you can compute about em to
the 1.4 instructions so this am to the
point for reuse which shows up here and
again there's tight bounds for sorting
okay so what I've what have I told you
so if I've told you that programs can be
modeled as DAGs and executions are
partitions and mapping mappings of
Diagon to the machine I given you a very
simple constructed I've taken this and
constructed very simple cost model for
distributed memory we've shown you upper
bounds and lower bounds but the problem
with this model is that the cost model
is entirely machine centric which means
that the cost model depends not only on
your algorithm but also on the machine
and the schedule okay now if you want to
understand the complexity of your
problem not only should you not only do
you have your energy into coming up with
Jen algorithm you have to also come up
with a schedule and often this is an
np-hard problem for for any for most non
trivial machine sent across models for
an arbitrary rag this is a
computationally intractable problem and
the biggest concern with this model is
that if you tie your costs down to the
machine on your schedule how are you
studying problem complex things so if if
someone comes comes along and says okay
what's the best algorithm that you can
do give what's the best scalable
algorithm for this problem and you're
talking in terms of machines then
there's something unsound about it so
you you you need you need a cleaner and
a more portable cost model that's not
tied down to the machine okay so so far
I've talked about a simple machine
centric cost model for distributed
memory machines the next part of the
talk will be about portable cost models
to do this what we do is we separate the
cost model from the scheduler from now
on what we'll try to do is to take it is
for each dag we will try to define a
metric that's
based entirely on the dag it doesn't
depend on your machine and we lost the
algorithm designer to restructure has
died call is algorithm so that it's good
in this cost model okay this cost model
which does not include any machine
parameters and once this algorithm
designer gives a stamp of approval for
this algorithm in terms of this cost
model you can build a scheduler for the
machine that you for your favorite
machine relation machines that you
bought and you can design a runtime or a
scheduler and prove bounds performance
bounds in terms of this portable metric
and the Machine parameters and if you
bought another machine you go and design
another one point for it or a scheduler
for it okay so that's the kind of
paradigm that I will try to show you in
the next second half of this talk and
how do we do this we do this by how do
we separate cost models and scheduler we
do this by making the cost model
portable and we do this by making the
cost model program centric so let me
define what a program sentry cost
modulus so to start with you have to
choose a portable program description or
dag will do because you know there's
nothing here that's machine centric and
you will analyze your dag without
reference to machine parameters no
process no cache is no connections so
you have to come up with rules to
quantify locality and parallelism in
this diet without any of these
parameters for instance these are
program centric matrix you can count the
number of operations which is work or
you can count the length of the critical
path it's just the depth or you can find
some data use pattern okay then to
quantify your locality you can do all of
this stuff but you can't talk about
machines and an interesting question
then is if you did in your analysis with
rest entirely based on your diet is
there anything meaningful that you this
analysis says about performance on
realistic machine models how do we how
do we justify this ok so the benchmark
for success is this if you can design a
metric that can capture performance or
you can design a bit if you can design a
metric which can be translated to
performance on
you have caches then I would say that
this this we succeeded in designing a
program sent across model so why am I
focusing on a tree of caches because it
is a fairly it's a very general and
realistic machine model it models the
hierarchical nature of locality it
models resource sharing because you know
we the sketch is being shared by
different sets of process and many
interconnects that you find in big
machines have a tree like interconnect
factories dragonfly etc and the other
things like grits etc can be
approximated with fries okay so we'll
try to come up with program centric cost
models and will test their validity by
saying if we can map them to a tree of
caches so that's this objective second
half a 30 objected now okay before we
jump into cost models for parallel
programs let's just stop and try to
design a cost model for sequential
algorithm okay I'll tell you about a
cost model cache oblivious framework
from a paper by frigo license lookup and
drums engine so in this program centric
cost model what you do is you take a
sequential program and think of running
it on an abstract machine with our with
what I with the cash and infinite size
memory this cache has size m and it's
organized into blocks of size B it's not
real machine it's just it's just a paper
calculation map this sequential program
to this abstract machine and count the
number of transfers that happen between
the cash in the memory okay so you have
to assume some sort of nice properties
on the caches I won't go into those
details but assuming some nice property
nice behavior about your cash about your
cash you can count the number of cache
misses a transverse between cash in
memory and we'll call that cash
complexity and we denoted by q1 and note
that it's a function of two parameters m
and B now you can compare this function
even if your program didn't know about
em and be in fact your program should
not know about M and B because remember
its program centric and you're not
supposed to know these parameters okay
so you can compare this function for
different values of M and B and the
variance of this function with respect
to MN be captures the
the temporal and spatial locality so if
you have a scan in this model if you'd
get you it would have n by B cache
misses what is telling us that a scan
has perfect spatial locality but zero
temporal locality because there's no m
here you can do matrix multiply a
recursive afraid fairly straightforward
divide and conquer matrix multiply and
you would get this bound which is
optimal and this has good facial ocala T
and also very good temporal locality and
same in the same case for sorting ok so
this is a program centric analysis for
sequential program and when you try to
run this program on a multi-level
hierarchy and if the cost of a cache
miss on the sidewalk asci for a level
like cash then you can bound you're
running time based on this analysis q1
by plugging in different values for
different levels in the cash so mi is
the size of the level I cash and CI is
the cost of the letter like Cashman so
you just multiply number of cache miss
red level I by the cost and some across
all levels in hierarchy okay so that's a
program centric analysis and the step of
bound based on the program centric
analysis okay so thanks for very simple
with sequential programs because you
know there is only one way you can in a
sequential program the difficult part
about parallel programs is that there
are many different artists in which you
can execute a parallel program and it
take it's a bit more complicated so will
now talk about a program centric model
called the battle cash complexity
framework which is joint work with the
lock Fineman and Philip Gibbons and in
this framework I'll give you 20 present
to complexity metrics the parallel cash
complexity for locality and effective
cash complexity which models both
locality and load imbalance and will
show how this these definitions lead to
a definition of paralyzed ability and
will also show that we can efficiently
map these cost models to a tree of
caches ok let's start and we and all
these cost models are only for nested
parallel dikes not for any die so what's
the nested parallel diagnosed with
parallel daggers one you can write with
for joint primitives or by constructing
a graph with only see
in parallel composition another way to
see this would be if you could organize
your instructions into strands tasks and
parallel blocks as follows so the
highest level highest level the program
at the highest level is a task and it's
a sequential composition of a strand
which is just a chain of instructions no
parallelism there and a parallel block
which is a parallel composition of
subtasks okay so that's a nested
parallel dike and i'll define this cost
model for nested parallel tags and note
that in a nested parallel track there
are no data dependencies between
parallels of task that's the main
condition here okay so first the first
definition is for locality this is
called the parallel cash complex
geometric how do we do how do you define
this take your dag and decompose it into
maximal em sighs subtask okay so here
this is your died this year program and
go and find the maximal em sighs
subtasks in this program there's three
of them in here and the fact that this
nested parallel program make this
decomposition unique and easily
computable now if you had an arbitrary
drag this would be impossible task but
if for nested parallel axis is trivial
and now that you have this decomposition
define this parallel cash complexity
function for every n size maximal
subtasks expect any reasonable scheduler
to load it once into the memory so just
count the space of nem fitting subtasks
and some overalls all subtasks okay so
you're loading this this task once into
the memory and reusing it without any
more cache misses and for every blue
note this that is a note that doesn't
fit in this sub task be pessimistic
don't assume any any reuse or any look
any use of locality in there and assume
that every instruction or every access
the cache nice okay so if you sum up
these two quantities you get
parallel cash complexity function so
that's the first program centric metric
now let's see if we can map this to a
tree of caches so for mapping this cost
model to a tree of caches you need a
scheduler and for scheduler and for
building a scheduler let's for now
assume that every task is annotated with
sighs you know the working set of each
of this task what you might do is find a
size mi task which is this unroll it
into size mi minus 1 tasks and pin this
task to level I cash and schedule a
subtask on this on the sub clusters okay
and you need to define the order in
which you will explore the subtask and
map them to this so i won't tell you
what this is but there's a good product
called the parallel depth-first and this
is what the scheduler does so at every
level in the hierarchy it finds for
every level in the hierarchy it finds
tasks that fit in here it unrolls this
task until it finds tasks that fit in
the next level of the hierarchy and it
goes and does particular order call the
parallel death first so that's the
scheduler we going to use another way to
look at the scheduler is to think in
terms of wave fronts okay so this is
your dad and this wave front corresponds
to all the tasks that are active on an
l2 cluster and this wave front one wave
front corresponds to toss a track to an
l1 plus so a scheduler another way to
think about the scheduler is is as a
bunch of nested wave fronts going
through this stack and scheduler has to
specify where and how large these wave
front sir okay now since we are mapping
mi size tossed em I sighs caches you
would expect the commune you expect good
communication costs specifically you
assume you would expect to get a Q star
of mi cache misses at every level and
that is true but the hard part about
this problem is bounding the time
bonding the time of the running time of
the scheduler it's difficult because
you're trying the number of process
available for a task to its size and if
you if your program is perfectly
balanced if you'd I guess it's like a
binary fork which is perfectly balanced
this is all fine you your runtime is
good
but if it's not then you have to
quantify how irregular or unbalanced
your task us for that we defined a new
metric called the effective cash
complexity what it does is extend
parallel cash complexity by adding the
cost of imbalance or by are trying to
quantify how difficult the diagnosis
schedule specifically it adds penalties
for long sequential strands which you
cannot paralyzed and parts of your DAGs
that look very imbalanced for instance
you might have a fork in which one of
this subtasks does a quadratic has a
quadratic kernel and this is a linear
kernel and if you try to schedule this
you might fail so if you have parts of
your computation that look like this you
add penalty for that and what you have
is a metric called effective cash
complexity it's telling you the it's
sterling the parallel cash complexity
plus the cost of I plus expected cost of
imbalance if you try to schedule this
dag on n to the Alpha process ok so this
funk this this this metric is a function
of alpha now this tag is entirely so
this metric is entirely program centric
this there's no machine parameters in
here and if you plot a graph that shows
you the behavior of the ratio of the
effective and the parallel cash complex
as a function of alpha it looks like
this for alpha equal to 0 it's one
because both of them are the same and
for some values of alpha they're about
the same and at a particular point in
diverges and that the point admission
that white divergence gives you tells
you how paralyzed about your algorithm
is this point is 1 for some was good
sorting algorithms and form a matrix
multiplication is 1.4 what it's telling
you is that this this this algorithm can
be effectively load-balanced to an end
to the 10 n cross at 0 in process okay
so this is a formal definition for
paralyzed ability of now to them and it
subsumes most previous matrix that you
might have seen okay so now I have this
effective cash complexity metric what am
I going to get out of it if you design a
good scheduler you can show that you can
achieve the scheduler Chiefs optimal
communication cost on a GF caches
that it has perfect load balance that
and it achieves optimal runtime which is
the sum of cost and each level in the
hierarchy divided by number of process
and you can also show that the scheduler
achieves good space bonds and this is
not an empty model you can design
algorithms that are optimal in this
model and here's a bunch of primitives
that are optimal in this model now all
of them have paralyzed ability one which
is which means that they can use 0 n
processors and all of them have optimal
parallel Akash complexities and how do
we achieve this we achieve this by
designing algorithms with low depth and
good parallel cash complexity and if you
combine these two usually you get good
effective cash complexity too ok so this
this this is a rule of thumb to get good
effective cash complex design algorithm
with low depth and really good guys trip
to a parallel cash complexity and it
will automatically automatically be load
balanced and the fact that you over
designed parallelism here the fact that
you design it 40 and process actually
helps you with lower bringing down
scheduling overheads in practice and
this algorithm scale well in practice
for instance of these are the sorting
algorithm here can sort about 100
million double precision numbers on
about in one second on a 32 cone machine
so that's that that's how fast these
algorithms are and you can use this
primitives to construct graph algorithms
that are extremely paralyzed will can
construct combinatorial algorithms I
think a not we'll talk about this out
with them you can construct an
approximation algorithm for sec tower
and so on ok in summary what have I told
you told you that it's very important if
you're trying to design a scalable
algorithm it's very important to
quantify locality and part listen and
depending on which model which machine
you're aiming to run your program on
there are many machines and Drake cost
models but if you are a theoretician and
someone told you to design a scalable
algorithm for this problem and you're
not bound to upon any particular machine
you don't have a favorite machine it
makes sense for you to design your
algorithms and measure them in a program
centric cost model and this is possible
because you can build
scheduler's and I've presented one such
program centric cost model and I've
showed you how I showed you that it's
you can design optimal algorithms here
you can translate into good performance
not just in theory but also in practice
and the final point I want to make is
that designs that the bounce that you
see in different cost models actually
look very similar quantitatively and if
you design your program in this program
cinta cost model and show that it scales
well you can reuse this ideas in most of
the cost models okay so that's another
added incentive to not be tied down to a
machine centric model that's if you if
you design in a program Sintek cost
model and get a good algorithm you can
use this ideas when you're trying to
design algorithms for specific machines
and it costs more so it's all I want to
say thank you